a peaceful day trip these three Syrian
patients are leaving the military
hospital in vestas data in lower saxony
for the first time they don't want their
real names to be made public or their
voices to be recognizable they're scared
of the consequences for their relatives
in Syria scared of Prime Minister Bashar
al-assad's henchmen Layla which is not
her real name and her four-year-old
daughter are plagued by nightmares their
bodies are full of shrapnel we were at
home when the bombing began our house
was hit and we were all there my husband
my children my son my husband was
injured and nobody came to help him
because the shooting continued when it
finally stopped both my son and husband
were dead
syria's civil war has raged on for more
than two years over 80,000 people have
died millions have fled with no end of
the fighting in sight the number of
victims continues to rise
for Achmed which is not his real name
it's still very alienating to be here in
Germany in a park where the plants are
so neatly ordered he left Syria after
his leg was seriously injured leaving
his wife and children behind I cook a
little I was arrested eight months after
the revolution began no reason was ever
given I was in jail for half a year I
was tortured and some of my fingernails
were pulled out a la fettle much as they
would like to forget the destruction
chaos and suffering they experienced the
patient's investors data are still
extremely traumatized it's terrible we
keep having nightmares about the bombs
we hear the Thunder when we're asleep as
if it were here in the hospital my
daughter dreams of her father dreams
that he's calling her 36 injured
patients were flown to Germany exactly a
month ago in a military air ambulance
most were very badly injured some were
in critical condition seven of them are
currently being treated at the military
hospital investors data senior surgeon
Andre gutka has already worked in many
war zones but has been particularly
moved by the plight of his Syrian
patients he was on Deficit estimate in
fear engines I was very emotional when I
saw the x-rays of the mother with the
four-year-old child and when I read the
child's file in what's a nice dog but
often ball he said I have a
four-year-old son myself and I was
really distressed by the thought there's
such a young innocent child had ended up
in such a life-threatening situation
the solace from the German Syrian forum
regularly come to visit the patients
here they talked to them about their
problems offer support and look after
them as well as they can Angela gutka
appreciates their help most of the
Syrians would like to remain in Germany
when they're better the authorities have
promised them they can Layla can imagine
staying with her daughter if her other
children can also come Achmed would also
prefer to leave Syria behind him I would
really like to stay in Germany if my
wife and children came they'd be able to
see what democracy and human dignity
really are Achmed also hopes his
war-torn homeland will one day be able
to experience democracy and he hopes
Germany will help fulfill this dream